[Music]
hey everybody I'm Igor and from Roxette
and I'm here to talk about schema-less
sequel
so before we start let me tell you
something about Roxette where I work at
and myself so rocks it is a seek search
and analytics engine and our goal is to
build make it very easy for you to build
data-driven applications we are a series
a start-up based in San Mateo California
and we are back by Greylock partners in
Sequoia before Rock said myself I was at
Facebook as a soft engineer working on
two projects rocks TB and graph KL
during my time there in my talk today
first I would like to introduce the
concept of hardware and people
efficiency talk about how these two
contrasts and what I mean when I say
those two and then I will talk about how
we at rocks at the designing systems for
people efficiency and there are three
technologies that we use and then I will
go into some technical details hope you
enjoy that which is schema-less sequel
converged indexing and service
architecture so what is Hardware
efficiency the other day I wanted to
know which database is the fastest in
the world and then Google the world's
fastest database and apparently all of
them are and I actually have one more
slide there's many more and when I when
you see I'm building the first fastest
database what I hear is you're making
hardware efficient you're making sure
that for my fixed workload that I have I
mean I can use less hardware I can spend
less than hardware so hardware
efficiency is how much hardware do I
need and faster databases usually mean I
am more Hardware efficient and it's very
important to be Hardware efficient but
my point I would like to make is that
it's not the only thing that matters
what also matters is people efficiency
and if hardware efficiencies how much
Hardware do I need for a particular
workload then people efficiency is how
many people do I need to get a job done
or to complete the project in the other
way to say that it's how much time do I
need how much overhead do I have to
spend to deal with particular tools and
to to get some insights from data sets
that I have
in there couple of ways where people
efficiency breaks down in today's world
and it plays data systems the first way
is hey Mac where is slow and then the
usual answer to that is Haiti you
index what's your partition key what's
your buffer size you have these ten
configuration parameters have you looked
and tuning those and in the end maybe
you should even hire DBA to figure this
all out for you the second example and
the big one is organizational friction
if you remember before cloud if your
application developer isn't and at an
enterprise company before you were able
to build your applications you had to go
to your provisioning department and ask
for ten machines and then they say okay
here are some forms fill that out we'll
talk to VP we'll see if we can get you
those ten machines and then between your
idea for the application then the day
when your application was actually
writing production it could take three
months of waiting for hardware
thankfully in the cloud era you have AWS
console you go there you may be on have
kubernetes we just deploy our
application just all runs on the
hardware you can get from a double yes
however we still have this concept of
data scientists being blocked on their
engineers for example there are
scientists discovers a new data set they
would like to explore visualize maybe
like try to see if there are some
insights out there but if the data side
if the data set is very big they have to
go talk to the other engineers and ask
them hey can you please set up on my
spark cluster so I can analyze this data
or can you you know do some material
processing for me to actually see what's
in the data set and usual data scientist
sometimes just say hey this data set is
not worth it for me to go talk to the
engineers they're very busy with my more
critical piece of projects and then
obviously pipelines I'm pretty sure I'm
not the first person using this xkd city
top comic in this conference but I'll
give you some time to read through it
pipelines are our favorite thing to hate
and and they are usually the reasons why
you know also people efficiency breaks
down you have pipelines you have to
monitor them they break you know schema
changes they break and you just don't
have data for that month or for that day
and it's usually very bad and when I
contrast hardware and people efficiency
what I usually see is that people or
organizations spend less money on
hardware than they spend on people and
then if you increase hardware efficiency
your organization will spend less money
that's great but if you increase people
efficiency if you make sure we're
and if you focus on reducing the amount
of time people have to spend the mundane
tasks maintaining pipelines for example
and less and you increase their time
they have in exploring different data
sets and getting this creative spark
creative insight this is overall great
win and you will not spend less money on
people but you will increase instead
increase creativity and actually add
huge value to your business potentially
in the second part of the talk I want to
explore how Roxette design systems for
people efficiency and sometimes at a
cost of hardware efficiency even let me
tell you a bit more about Roxette as I
said before we are search analytics
engine and what we're building is a
shortest path from data to applications
and to think of rocks it as a you know
tool you can think of it as you can
connect to existing data streams or data
sources it can be also real time and
then rocks it ingests those data sources
into our own internal a system and then
you can execute very fast queries on it
now how would we choose a query language
obviously if in today's world if you're
building a data system and you want to
expose it to your customers you want to
use sequel because sequel and way
maximizes usefulness of your data of
your data system there's a lot of people
who understand sequel and a lot of tools
that work with sequel and let you query
drill down and visualize your data sets
so sequel is the most obvious choice but
sequel has one big issue which is let's
say you have existing data sources let's
here a data scientist and you want to
explore let's say Twitter data and you
want to explore some data that lives in
the data Lake you want to explore some
sensor data you want to connect all
these together sequel is great but first
you have to define a schema and then you
have sensor data it's a third party
provider they have a firmware update and
now the data that's coming in doesn't
conform to your schema now you don't
have the data anymore you have to go
talk to the engineers and this whole
system is broken so what we see is that
sequel schema is a very big drag on
people efficiency because data is
usually messy it doesn't conform to one
schema and then you have to build very
complex ETL jobs to actually get data
from your source to your destination
that has to have a schema to create
efficiently
what we do a Roxette is we decided to
use a sequel but not have a schema and
we called a schema less sequel what this
allows us to do is to allows us to
ingest any data that you might have
without any blockers you just point us
to data set whatever format it's in
because you don't have a schema you can
just pull in and ingest it into Roxette
however we still build a smart schema
and now this is an exchange concept to
understand but we show the customer of
what is the schema in the data set they
ingest into Roxette well in the code we
actually never use that people sometimes
ask me how do you you know optimize your
sequel queries we do not use a scheme
sequel schema as a concept in our code
but there is a special specific query
you can run to actually see what how
your data set looks like in Roxette and
now we call the smart scheme and if you
download the slides later you can see
this slide the link at the bottom of the
slide where you can learn more about
smart schema and we talk about data when
we talk to data scientists they use
roxelle what they say we I'm finally
independent I can finally I have my data
set I don't have to go talk to data
engineer I can just ingest it into
Roxette and explore it a couple seconds
later or basically immediately and this
is a huge win for them in terms of
productivity and this is what we talk
about we talk about people efficiency
however obviously if you don't have a
schema you will lose something on
performance so it's not going to
technical details of how we actually
solve performance overheads and what is
the performance overhead or not having
the schema versus having a strict schema
so how do we tolerate this hardware
efficiency loss and the first obvious
part is storage if you had the strict
schema in this first row on the slide
you have the schema where the name is a
string and ages an integer then when you
in quote the data set you know exactly
how the data set looks like you don't
have to encode what's the type of the
field you know John is a string and
fortifies integer and using the schema
that's strictly defined you know exactly
that John is the name and then 45 is an
age in the first version of rocks at
schema-less implementation what we did
is you don't have a schema so instead in
every single row in the database we have
to encode both the field name for each
field the field type string and
the field value so in this case we have
name which is a string and it's John and
then we have age which is an integer in
35 so if you think about it if every
single one of your records has a name in
it we and you have billion records we
repeat name string in a data set billion
times and that's obviously not you know
very efficient however at some point we
decided to do this technique called
field interning and what I mean by field
interning is we maintain a map between
field names and ID's and if the document
comes into Roxette and we see a field
name that we never seen before we add it
to the map assign the unique ID and then
in the data itself we do not have to
store a field name we only store field
ID so now instead of very long field
names you store integers and I think
this saved I think about 30 percent of
storage on this that we used so even
though we still have to encode types so
we still have to say field ID 0 is a
string john field ID 1 is an integer 35
we still have a huge win by not having
to store field names
the second piece where we lose out on
Harvey efficiency is query execution
performance and here what I'm talking
about is you when you execute the query
you load some data from disk and you put
in this in memory format and then this
in memory format this in memory blob
travels through the sequel operators to
actually compute the results of the cray
it can go through aggregators joins and
so on and if you have the strict schema
you know exactly what types you are
expecting and your in memory
representation can be very very
efficient so in this example again on
the first row we see how in memory
representation looks like within strict
schema we see we have two columns here
and five rows first column is all
integers and second column is all
strings and then we can just encode
those in memory is vector of integers
just a flat array and that can be done
and you can do processing on it very
very efficiently in naive schema-less
worldö in the second row what you have
is you cannot have vector of integers
because you do not know that all them
are integers but you have vector of some
type that's generic and then inside of
this generic type you have the field tag
you say this is an integer it's one this
is an integer it's 10 this is integer
it's 7 and so on and this
issue for the second column where you
have mixed types we have this is a
string it's an A and some of them is an
integer and it's an integer what you
have when you pass this blob into your
sequel operators is for every single
element you have this type dispatch you
have to check is this an integer then
execute this function if it's a string
execute that function and if you do this
billion times over it's very very slow
it kills your CPU cache so instead what
we did is we have this technique called
type hoisting and what type of hosting
does is when as we are building this
block we are remembering are all values
in this column of the same type if they
are then we encode this information the
header of the blob or of the page and in
code all the fields for that column
efficiently so in this case we can see
that the first column we have everything
is an integer so we encode I this is an
integer in the header and then
everything else just is a very efficient
vector of integers in the second column
because you have mixed types we say this
is still a mixed type so I look in line
for the information about types and now
if you actually have the same implicit
schema if all of your field type for
particular field type all types are the
same you can still have the sufficient
execution but if your fields are mixed
it still works it's still ok which is
just a little bit slower in conclusion
for this schema less sequel allows us to
provide the superior user experience if
you have a data set you can ingest into
Roxette it all just works we do lose out
on hardware efficiency but there are
techniques we use to actually make this
overhead smaller we use filled interning
to reduce storage overhead and then we
use type hoisting to reduce query
execution speed the second technique
technique I want to talk about is
converge indexing conversion next thing
is Roxette solution to the problem of
query slow because I'm missing an index
so what's our solution index all the
fields madness right before I talk a
little bit more about technically what
is conversion next thing I want to talk
a little bit about background on corner
storage and Search Indexing
how many of you are familiar with corner
storage ok so I can go
faster over the next couple slides so
corner storage as opposed to row storage
is where I store data such that I store
each column separately and what this
allows me to do is allows me to compress
the column values very very well because
colonizer very similar to each other and
similar values compress better and then
when I'm executing the queries I only
can fetch columns that the query needs
even though my table can have many many
columns if my query is touching only a
couple I can execute that very very
efficiently and some examples of systems
that use columnar storage is vertical
Amazon redshift and bigquery which I'm
sure most of you have heard about now
this is an example of how I would encode
two documents in columnar store let's
say I have two documents document 0 with
fields name interests and less active
and same thing with document 1 on the
right hand side you can see how would
this corner store or presentation of
these two documents look like obviously
we want to store each column separately
so for a column name we would store
document at the 0 and the value is Igor
document ID 1 and the value juba the
same thing is true for interests and
last active advantages of columnar
storage is it's very very cost effective
as I said before the compression ratios
are great which means I get to save
money it also works very well for narrow
queries and white tables so if your
table has a lot of columns and you only
query in a couple of columns versus
Joomla well and then the execution of
corners over corner stores usually scan
based you need to scan through the
entire data set you don't actually have
an index and as such it works very well
for a little quiz that have to scan the
entire data set however on the
disadvantages side most corner stores
out there have very high write latency
what that means is when you insert data
into your corner store it takes a couple
seconds maybe even a couple minutes to
actually reflect that change in your
quiz as well because the queries are all
scan based your read latency minimum you
can achieve is very high it's usually a
couple seconds sometimes you in a couple
minutes
and if your minimum reading six couple
seconds you cannot put corner store in
an online application it's not suitable
for all applications and people usually
don't use you that way
on the other side we have Search
Indexing in Search Indexing such systems
such as elasticsearch solar which are
both based on leucine for each value you
store a list of documents that contain
that value in a data structure called
posting lists and what Search Indexing
allows you to do is if you have a
particular predicate you can quickly
retrieve a list of document IDs that
match that predicate let's go back to
our original two documents we have
documents your document one again on the
right-hand side you can see how would
encoding of those document in Search
Indexing look like so we still have each
column separately but now we basically
flip the document ID and the document
value so now instead of storing 0 maps
to Igor you say Egor maps to 0 and then
rubra maps to 1 and then interests you
see databases maps to document 0 index 0
it's an array and also a document 1
index 1 and so if you want to learn
about who's interesting databases you
can quickly look with the Search
Indexing
the advantages are if you have a highly
selective predicate and highly selective
query squares a touch only small portion
of your data set it can be very very
fast and as such executes very low
latency queries and it's suitable for
online applications elastic search
Google search all others are used in
online applications where somebody some
customers waiting for your result
however people usually don't run
analytical queries on search datasets
you don't want to do that it's less
efficient than if you use pure columnar
storm in converge indexing it would
probably it's probably not a surprise
it's combining corner and search indexes
in the same system and to present
commercial indexing it's important to
understand the key value storage
actually build it on so key value store
abstraction you can think of it as it's
something that you can insert key value
pairs into you can achieve a value for
particular key and you can also do range
index arrange queries on a sort of view
of the data set and we use rocks to be
for that purpose in our case but you can
converge indexing can be built on any
sort of key value store that presents
your data in sorted order that's
important each document that comes in
two rocks it or any other coverage
indexing system maps to many key value
pairs
and to explore let's go back to a
document zero document one but it make
it a little bit simpler now where we
only care about name field and we have
ego in Juba on the right hand side you
can see how those two documents would be
encoded in a key value format in
converged indexing system so what we
have is we first insert the document
into row store and enroll store the
first component of the row store key is
document ID and the second component is
the column name so in this case you can
see document ID zero name and then value
is eager and so what you can see here is
if I want to fetch one document I can do
it quickly with a row store because I I
store all the values for a particular
document close together because document
ID is the first component of my key I
can just find all the keys that have
prefix are zero and I find all the
values for a particular document then I
have a column store where I flip the
document ID and the column name so now
column name is the first component of
the key and the document is the second
book second component of the key and for
my operation saying finally all values
for a particular column column store is
the fastest thing we can do I can just
find all keys with prefix e dot name and
find all names in our data set and we
store column values close together so it
it's very similar to existing column
store and then for search index document
ID goes to the final place in the key so
my key starts with column name then
there's a column value and then finally
call them a document IDs at the end and
if I want to find for example all
documents where name is equal to juban I
go into the key value store and look for
s named Aruba prefix and once I find
that I find all the documents that for
which name is equal to true bar exam so
for any questions and this is going a
bit technical but I hope you like it so
the question was does it we use speed
when we are writing because now every
document it's not actually three times
because for every field in the document
we produce three key value pairs so it's
three times number of number of fields
in the document
so now when we do queries I can do fast
ethical craze and fast search queries
and then the optimizer picks between the
column store or search index based on
the cray so for example if I had a claim
where for search logs that's a Google
search logs I want to find out who
searched for data counsel within LOC l
equals English my optimizer would say ok
this is a grave it very highly selective
filter I'm going to use a search index
and this is query is going to be fast
and very low latency because it's going
to use a search index and then in the
same system if I ask for findme
frequency of keywords and let's say you
know sort by by the frequency in this
case the optimizer will pick columnar
store and and because we use columnar
store
we will only actually fetch the values
for keyword we will not fetch any other
values for the for those documents so
this is also going to be very efficient
query by using columnar store and then
on the writes the question before was
because one docking writes results in
many key value store writes how do we
actually make sure that this is not too
costly and what we do is we use a write
optimized key value store which is Roxie
be how many of you have heard of rocks
TV before ok great if you know good
number so with background on rocks DB
and why do we call it it's a write
optimized key value store so rocks DB
utilizes this technique called log
structure merge trees where all the keys
that are inserted into rocks DB our
first reside in this in memory read
buffer that we call mem table only when
the main table is full we take the whole
mem table and flush it to disk and so
you think about what happens is you have
a lot of random writes but you're
turning them into sequential writes on
storage and this is and as you're
turning them into sequential writes you
can also compress it very well and this
is why we call it write optimized key
value store and then once you have a lot
of files on storage you also have
background compaction which takes those
files and merges them together
one thing that's important to remember
about rocks DB that rocks do these files
on disk are immutable as soon as you
write them you never change it again
the only thing you do is you compact it
with others and then produce new files
and this will become important later on
to conclude converge indexing gives us
fast quiz out-of-the-box and it also
supports real-time index right so
previously I said that corner stores are
not great when it comes to right Layton
sees because we use a key value store
for our corner store we can execute real
time index writes when you insert a
document to Roxette it appears in your
index usually a couple hundred
milliseconds later and let's see
trade-offs between converge indexing are
not doing that the trade-off is more
efficient this database configuration
and we have more efficient ways on the
less efficient side obviously use more
storage than the traditional solutions
and our rights are heavier but if you
think about it both storage and writes
are hardware efficiency we can spend
more money on hardware and what's more
efficient here is database configuration
something people have been you know
dealing with for many many years where
how do I build the perfect index you
don't have to all the index is already
built and overhead of dealing with the
tool is reduced and then your craze are
also faster which is you're waiting for
the you know your analyst or your
customers waiting for the credit to
complete so you want that to be as fast
as possible and in my mind this is win
this is a win on people efficiency and
you lose some of our efficiency but you
actually care more about people
efficiency in this case it's a win and
then finally we have service
architecture and service architecture is
you know probably obvious to all of us
that it's a giant improvement when it
comes to designing people efficient
systems Roxette is delivered as a cloud
service which means you don't have to
manage any hardware you as a customer
just you know use rocks it through the
REST API and that's it there's no
hardware to manage however in the
service architecture what's very
important is to produce seamless auto
scale if I'm not managing hardware then
what happens if my load increases what's
going to happen I need I need more
hardware I need more compute power in
the background and service architecture
when you have stateless systems it's
easy not easy not not trivial but it's
easier than when you have stateful
architecture when your systems have
stayed that store it's very hard to
actually
get more compute that way and so I won't
talk about how we actually achieve that
in Roxette how we achieve scalability
out of this Auto scale when we have
stateful services and to do that I first
have to introduce you to the rocks its
architecture and I'll just be brief here
but so we have the first layer here just
rocks at sequel API which is just the
REST API that we exposed to customers
and does all the authentication
authorization permission checks and all
so on then the second layer we have is a
layer of aggregators which are stateless
compute here which are executing sequel
queries and finally the third tier we
have is leaves which are storage Leafs
storage nodes that store data locally in
rocks the be instances and data is
charted across many leaves in those
rocks if instances the writes are all
going to this distributed log on in the
green green color and then Leafs are
tailing the rights to the log to make
sure they're up there all up to date now
the what we actually use is not rocks DB
we use this extension of rocks did we
call rocks to be cloud that via rocks
are developed and also open source so
you can find it on github and what rocks
the big cloud does is it takes SSD files
that Roxie B produces remember they're
immutable and upload them to the cloud
to the cloud object storage you can
think with s3 you know GCS Mineo Azure
storage and all the others so as soon as
the rocks DB creates a file which is
immutable
it uploads it to the cloud and what that
does it keeps the consistent snapshot
off database in the cloud at all times
and now let's say your new customer
comes in they started a lot of craze or
your load increases what do you do what
you do is you create a new read replica
you create a new leaf machine you open a
rocks DB cloud database and you point
rocks typical database to existing s3
bucket and then this rocks DB cloud
database copies all the SSD files from
the s3 bucket this is usually very fast
because s3 has great throughput and
you're not disturbing any of the
existing replicas that they're very busy
serving this this workload because we've
said we are adding rate
replicas because we are already very
busy we do not want to add it another
load to our poor leaf machines so we
download the data from s3 and we start
serving the data but before that we have
to tell you updates from the log when we
copy the data from s3 we have snapshot
of a database that's usually a couple
seconds maybe a couple minutes old
so we subscribe to the updates from the
log to make sure that our state is
up-to-date and all the rights are
reflected once we know that we have
caught up then we register with the
aggregator and say hey I'm here I can
serve I can help out I can serve more
quays and this is how we can achieve
scalability even when our system is
stateful this is not instant process
unfortunately it takes a couple minutes
but coupl means later you have more
compute power and you can satisfy a
higher load and finally in the
conclusion what the three techniques I
talked about schema-less sequel allows
us no need to configure any schemas you
can just insert data as it is from
wherever it is converge indexing allows
us to not have to configure any indexes
and service architecture allows us to
not have to configure any servers and we
have not built the world's fastest
database but I believe we have built the
shortest path to go from data to
applications and the reason we did that
is because we believe as soon as you
make tools easier to use and you make
workforce easier this catalyzes
creativity in your organization thank
you oh good talk thank you I got a
couple of questions just to clarify the
architecture so and maybe I missed them
in which case forgive me so one question
is what's in the log is it is it data or
is it stuff like this file was out of
this files removed and the second
question is what charting strategy do
you use to determine which data goes in
which rocks DB instance very good
question so in the log all the new
updates that are coming in are written
to the log first and then they are
tailed by the leaf machines which then
write them to their local rocks DB
instances and the data is charted in doc
shard of the way so each document lives
on exactly one leaf machine and it's
replicated to one or two more
we chartered based on primary ID primary
key ID and then just you know sharding
function a hashing function and a modulo
number of shards I have one does your
converged indexing make query plane and
more query planning more simple or less
simple I think so for query planning I
would say simpler but we still have to
build a full query optimization
framework so we still build full query
framework because we need to decide
between you know selectivity not
selectivity and so we have very complex
rules that we build they say explore
these different query plans and score
them and then choose the best one so
there are some pieces that are more
simple about the framework is still very
similar to the existing framers that
other systems in the query optimization
have hi Thank You Igor um so I guess I
have two questions on the schema-less
side would you look at any of the
research on dependent typing out of
egress anything like that to think about
how to handle that I look it looks like
there's probably some efficiencies that
could be gained by looking at some of
the stuff that's coming out of the FP
world I'm sorry which world I'm actually
not functional programming world okay um
so II trous is an offshoot of Pascal or
a flavour of Haskell has dependent
typing so if you think about like how
you would express a sequel table that
had a heterogeneous set of couple types
it would be a union type of those oh I
see
and how do you think about like you know
breaking up a union type bucket and what
are some efficiencies that could be
gained so I guess that's my first
question the second question was um in
this in using rocks DB like writing
three sets of data did you explore using
our tree indexes at all instead of using
that to fit a tree based model mm-hmm
that's actually a very the second quick
so first
question I'm a unfortunately not aware
that research I would be very happy to
talk I think we have time in office
hours to talk a bit more about that for
the second question is actually a very
good question of arch indexes and what
we have explore Archie indexes not yet
built is range queries on numeric types
so if you have numeric types in your
data set search indexes are usually
quite bad for that for some some deeply
technical reasons and what we actually
build is we build this multi-dimensional
indexes and we would like to have the
multi-dimensional indexes where we have
index range of values and right so
values from like 10 to 20 we build one
index for those and then range from 20
to 30 we build another index for those
in this very Explorer building archery
indexes or any kind of range indexing
but what we did is we build a static
indexing for those so we build static
ranges and then if your value falls into
the static range then index in that
range and I would like to build arteries
but it's kind of hard to integrate those
well with Roxie beam I think at some
point people have to and we will but so
far we have static range indexing that
kind of serves it the purpose of
arteries in our system but it's yeah
it's not as good as our trees themselves
in the crater space we'll use the space
building curve like a helmet yeah that's
what you do you could use a one
dimensional index rather than going to
be
trees which are so that's exactly what
we do and for four locations we do
space-filling curves you actually use
Google's s2 library but and then ya be
used rocks TV which is a single
dimensional index but I don't know I
have not actually explore whether
building arteries within rock CB would
be better than using rocks a bit and
sell as a one-dimensional index but so
far yes we are doing this as one
dimension X because it's easier that's
for sure
question so it sounds like from the talk
that this is a pendulum is that correct
no this is so because we are we have
frogs DB as in sorry I did I did not
talk much about rock CB itself in terms
of the capabilities we provide but we
use rocks DB which produce which can
which supports you know
read-modify-write writes deletes so we
do support basically any kind of writes
to the database cool yeah that was just
my question yeah thank you
[Music]